the hours are ticking by
and tensions are ticking up
this is where votes from arizona's
largest county are being processed
not well enough according to some if
there was any chance for any type of
fraud
which donald trump's been calling for
for four months why would they let this
go to chance
this isn't a large group but their views
hang heavy around this election
and the future of america some people
out there actually think that we do need
some kind of a civil war some kind of
uprising because
this is exactly what's going on when you
try to take the voice away from the
people
the people fight back so i'm not worried
about it because i do know that a lot of
patriots will rise up and that we will
take back
what we believe should be ours so you
really seriously think that people will
rise up
against a legitimate democratic system i
think so
the race here is razer tight a knife
edge state that could tip
a knife edge election joe biden's
leading but only just
and there's a sense they're bracing
securities being increased here counting
could continue for a number of days yet
getting it right has rarely been so
important
if it transpires arizonans have backed
joe biden it'll be a huge moment
loaded with significance and symbolism
and that's because this state has
historically voted republican
they've only backed a democrat for
president once in 68 years
but it also has an independent even
maverick spirit and an awareness of how
much is at stake
if it goes the right way i'd be terribly
proud i can't say that i wouldn't be
but if it doesn't i would be devastated
we're pretty tough people if you shoot
at me i'm shooting to you
it's that kind of you know it's that
kind of attitude so
with all the democrats and liberals and
this and that coming over
you don't know where you're standing
anymore it's a 50-50 state now
change here is being driven by
demographics more
young urban and latino voters chef
sylvana campaigned for biden
she's confident those voters made it to
the polls in large enough numbers
i feel hopeful i feel somber i feel sad
that
so many people voted for donald
trump i questioned america a question
are you voting with your pocketbook or
your conscience
you know because if it's your conscious
i'm really scared and if it's your
pocketbook
how selfish of you many here say they
just want it all to be over
but even once the counting has finished
that could be a while off
helen and smith sky news arizona